foreign
[Music]
and I'm here to talk about the future of
missing data
so I fully hate missing data it disrupts
your data analysis because you need to
stop and work out how much is missing
and think why is it missing why
missing data controls messages I mean
imagine if what I said just then it was
bleeped out you might get a different
idea of what I was saying
I redacted paid missing data it redacted
new data analysis because redacted and
work out how redacted is missing and
think why redacted and redacted redacted
why
but the truth is I actually love missing
data
a funny way
understanding it's hard but it has an
extra challenge a little bit of spice to
a data analysis and it's been something
that I found really exciting and curious
about a data analysis project
I've actually written two art packages
to help explore your data and explore
missing data
and today I'm going to talk about two
things a principle of going from
overview to relationship to explore your
missing data and a brief tour of missing
data visualizations emphasis on the
brief I won't have time to explore them
all in detail
so the first one I'd recommend is an
overview viz miss this gives you a
bird's eye view of your missing data
here the rows are your observations and
the columns are your variables
if we look at the data here we see that
the black spots here are missing and the
gray are present and what we take away
from this is that air temperature C
is missing and humidity is also missing
they have two big chunks of missing data
there's also a few times where there's
these black streaks and that indicates
that some variables go missing together
we also know that there is um extra
information on the amount of missing in
each variable so there's 11 missing an
air temperature and 12 missing in
humidity
so now we go from the overview here and
we take these two variables that are
interesting to us that I have a lot of
missing let me plot them together to
explore a relationship
we can do this with GT plot with air
temperature on the x-axis and humidity
on the y-axis but we get a little
interesting problem here which says that
it's removed 107 rows containing missing
values so how do you show
these values that are removed how do you
show missing values if they're missing
you can use geom Miss point this is a
regular Gigi plot GM and this will
impute the values of the data to be
um
lower than the range of the data so
they're sort of off to the side here and
in a different color so let's break this
down and look at each axis one at a time
the values in red on the x-axis are air
temperature values which are missing for
humidity we see that the distribution of
these values here matches the first
cluster on the left
and on the y-axis are the humidity
values that have missing air temperature
values interestingly again here is that
this cluster value seems to match the
second cluster on the right of the
present values here so what we learned
from this is that missing this is a line
of these two classes of air temperature
and humidity
and let's explore this further by
exploring this relationship with another
variable yeah
we can just use facet wrap here just
like a regular DJ plot GM we then get
two subplots here
what we notice is something very
interesting
that we get these different values for
for these these distributions of
missingness are shown for each of these
different years and we've learned
something really interesting there's a
different missing value pattern for each
year
now I'm going to briefly explore some
more missing data visualizations
so you can use gtms VAR to explore the
missingness in each variable and you can
even show this instead of their number
to the percent and you can even explore
this with a facet uh hey look we found
it again the pattern of missing values
for each year in our data set
igne's teaching is upset to explore
combinations of missingness in simple
data sets or more complex ones
you can even use GTE Miss factor to
explore the percent of missings of all
variables grouped by another Factor here
we see the percent of missing data over
all variables in this data set for these
different levels of marital status
with some help from the Arkansas sure
I'm really happy to say we'll be adding
some more tools for visualizing missing
data I'll briefly talk about two new
additions that I think will be really
cool
geometry histogram will show the amount
of missing values alongside a univariate
distribution by impeding below the range
of the data this gives us a general
sense of the amount of missing
values in the air temperature data here
in this example
geomputed point will take in a data set
and identify any imputed values will
also show
the values that are missing
and in some very exciting news I would
love to introduce a book
that I'm working with Alison Holst
called The Missing book it contains
exercises on missing data and General
workflows on exploring and missing
values and imputations and the aim is to
have a general book to guide you through
exploring your data with some case
studies of real missing data
so I'll wrap up now by saying that the
future of missing data is its presence
it's its presence in software in your
data analysis in tutorials and how we
think about data generally
funnily enough missing data is almost
always present so let's make sure we
don't forget it
[Music]